YOU ASKED THEM TO RELEASE
CONSCIENCE MACHINES.
JOINING US NOW FOX NEWS
CONTRIBUTOR AND FOX NEWS
REPORTER SARA CARTER AND FOX
NEWS LEGAL ANALYST GREGG
JARRETT FORMER DEPUTY
ASSISTANT TO THE PRESIDENT
SEBASTIAN GORKA.
IT WAS MARCH 8TH OF LAST
YEAR YOU AND JOHN SOLOMON ON
THIS SHOW BROKE THIS STORY
OF THE FISA WARRANT AND
SURVEILLANCE OF TRUMP TOWER.
AND HOW FEW IN THE MEDIA
SCARED TO FOLLOW WHAT IS THE
SARA?
>> IT'S INCREDIBLE, SEAN.
BECAUSE THERE WAS SO MUCH
EVIDENCE OUT THERE.
LITTLE BITS OF EVIDENCE THAT
IF THEY JUST LATCHED ON TO
IT, THEY WOULD HAVE BEEN
ABLE TO SEE THROUGH AND SEE
THE TRUTH.
THEY CHOSE NOT TO.
ADMINISTRATION AND PEOPLE
ASSOCIATED WITH HILLARY
CLINTON AND NOW WE KNOW
FUSION G.P.S. CHRISTOPHER
STEELE, BRUCE OHR AND THE
DOJ, SALLY YATES, ANDREW
MCCABE AT THE FBI.
THEY TRIED TO SAY THAT IT
WAS THE RUSSIANS.
BUT THE WHOLE TIME BASED ON
AN UNVERIFIED AND SALACIOUS
DOSSIER AND THOSE ARE THE
WORDS COMING OUT OF COMEY'S
OWN MOUTH, THEY USED THAT TO
SPREAD LIES ABOUT THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN TO THE MEDIA AND
ANYBODY THEY COULD TRY TO
SHARE IT WITH.
THE MEDIA BOUGHT IT.
AND THEY CHOSE TO IGNORE THE
OTHER SIDE.
THEY CHOSE TO ASK FOR
VERIFICATION.
AND THE ENTIRE PRECEDENCE OF
THE SPECIAL COUNSEL WAS
BASED ON THAT DOSSIER
ACCORDING TO MCCABE.
>> Sean: YOU KNOW, I EVEN
HAVE TESTIMONY, I DON'T HAVE
THE TIME TO DISPLAY IT
OUGHT.
SO MUCH INFORMATION TO GET
OUT TONIGHT, GREGG JARRETT
REMEMBER WHEN HE, COMEY, MET
WITH DONALD TRUMP, HE SAID
IT'S UNVERIFIED AND IT'S IS
HE LEGS.
SALACIOUS.
TWO MONTHS EARLIER HE WAS
CAME FROM AND THEY NEVER
TOLD THE FISA COURT.
CRIMINALLY SPEAKING, IS HE N
JEOPARDY TONIGHT?
IT'S SAD.
THE FBI AND THE DEPARTMENT
OF JUSTICE THEY CONCEALED
EVIDENCE AND THEY DECEIVED A
FEDERAL JUDGE.
THEY KNEW THIS WAS A
FABRICATED DOCUMENT.
KNEW IT WAS PAID FOR BY
DEMOCRATS AND HILLARY
CLINTON.
THEY KNEW THAT THE GUY WHO
AUTHORED IT SAID HE WAS
DESPERATE TO STOP TRUMP AND,
YET, THEY USED IT.
THEY SIGNED A DOCUMENT IN
FRONT OF A JUDGE THAT SAID
WE VOUCH FOR THE RELIABILITY
AND AUTHENTICITY OF THIS
DOCUMENT AND IN OTHER WORDS
THEY WERE LYING TO THE
JUDGE.
THAT'S A CRIME.
18 U.S. C 242.
IT'S ABUSE OF POWER.
AND IT'S TRAGIC THAT THE
PEOPLE THAT WE EXPECT TO
UPHOLD AND ENFORCE THE LAW
IS WHAT THEY DO.
THEY KNEW THE DOSSIER WAS
FALSE.
THEY KNEW THAT HILLARY
CLINTON PAID FOR THE
THEY KNEW THE GUY THAT WAS
RESPONSIBLE, STEELE HATE YOU
HAD DONALD TRUMP AND DIDN'T
WANT HIM TO WIN.
THEY KNEW THEY COULDN'T SPY
ON A TRUMP ASSOCIATE WITHOUT
THE DOSSIER.
THEY WERE SHUT DOWN THE
FIRST ATTEMPT THEY TRIED TO
GET IT AND THEN THEY GOT IT
ON THE SECOND SHOT AND ADMIT
WITHOUT IT THEY NEVER WOULD
HAVE GOT IT?
>> SEAN, LET'S JUST REMEMBER
WHAT HAPPENED 11 MONTHS AGO.
THE PRESIDENT TWEETED OUT
THAT HIS CAMPAIGN HAD BEEN
SPIED UPON.
HE WAS RIDICULED BY THE LEFT
AND THE MAINSTREAM MEDIA.
WE NOW KNOW NOT ONLY IS IT
TRUE THAT HE WAS SPIED UPON
BY THE OBAMA ADMINISTRATION,
BUT THE WARRANT WAS A
REQUIRED ILLEGALLY.
I HAD A CHIEF OF POLICE TEXT
ME TODAY AND HE SAID IF ANY
OF HIS OFFICES HAD ACQUIRED
A WARRANT WHILE EXCLUDING
EXCULPATORY INFORMATION,
THAT OFFICER WOULD BE
CHARGED WITH PERJURY OR
ABUSE OF POWER.
NOT ONLY THAT THIS IS
FASCINATING.
LET'S UNWIND ALL OF IT.
CONGRESSMAN GATES JUST
REMINDED ME ON THE 16TH OF
MAY, ROD ROSENSTEIN ESCORTED
TO BE THE DIRECTOR OF THE
FBI AGAIN.
HE FAILED THE INTERVIEW.
THE PRESIDENT WANTED
SOMEBODY NEW.
HE DIDN'T WANT A BUSH ERA
PERSON.
THE NEXT DAY, MAY THE 17TH,
AFTER HE FAILED THAT
INTERVIEW, ROD ROSENSTEIN
APPOINTS HIM AS THE SPECIAL
COUNSEL TO INVESTIGATE.
>> Sean: UNBELIEVABLE.
>> THE PRESIDENT.
HOW CAN HE INVESTIGATE THE
PRESIDENT IN A OBJECTIVE
FASHION.
AND LASTLY, LASTLY, WHAT
ABOUT ALL THE CONGRESS MEN
AND WOMEN WHO LIED ABOUT
THIS MEMO?
FOR FOUR DAYS THEY HAVE BEEN
TELLING US IT WOULD REVEAL
SOURCES AND METHODS.
>> Sean: THAT'S PAR FOR THE
COURSE.
>> NO SOURCES AND METHODS.
>> Sean: LET ME GO TO SARAH.
SARAH, IT WAS ABOUT A YEAR
AGO YOU BROKE THIS STORY.
MY SOURCES TELL ME THIS IS
JUST THE TIP OF THE SPEAR,
COME.
I WAS GIVEN A PERCENTAGE,
ABOUT 15% OF WHAT IS COMING.
WHAT ARE YOUR SOURCES
TELLING YOU?
YOU WERE DEAD ON ACCURATE ON
MARCH 8TH OF LAST YEAR.
>> MY SOURCES ARE TELLING ME
IT'S 10% OF WHAT IS COMING.
SO MAYBE THERE IS EVEN MORE,
SEAN, OUT THERE THAN WHAT WE
EXPECT.
I KNOW THAT MEMBERS OF
CONGRESS ARE GOING TO CALL
FOR A SPECIAL COUNSEL TO
INVESTIGATE THE
INVESTIGATORS.
THERE IS GOING TO BE A
NUMBER OF PEOPLE INVOLVED IN
THIS.
ALSO, THE INFORMATION AS YOU
REPORTED THAT'S GOING TO BE
WAS
CRS
CRIMINALITY HERE.
FROM WHAT APPEARANCES LOOK
LIKE, THERE WAS.
THEY LIED TO THE FISA COURTS
ALLEGEDLY.
THAT'S WHAT THEY ARE GOING
TO BE LOOKING AT.
I TELL YOU, SEAN, THIS IS
JUST OUT BEGINNING.
THIS IS NOT THE END.
AND THE INVESTIGATION IS IN
REVERSE.
>> Sean: LAST THOUGHTS,
WHERE IS THIS GOING?
>> I DON'T KNOW.
BUT I CAN TELL YOU A
CONGRESSIONAL SOURCE TELLS
ME THAT ROD ROSENSTEIN IN A
MEETING THREE WEEKS AGO
THREATENED THE CHAIRMAN
NUNES AND MEMBERS OF
CONGRESS THAT HE WAS GOING
TO SUBPOENA THEIR TEXTS AND
MESSAGES BECAUSE HE WAS
TIRED OF DEALING WITH THE
INTEL COMMITTEE.
THAT'S A THREAT AND
INTIMIDATION AND
RETALIATION.
>> Sean: ALL OF YOU HAVE
BEEN DOING THE WORK OF THE
MEDIA FOR AN ENTIRE YEAR AND
SHARING IT WITH OUR